you got a lot going on because you are
one of few stars out there right now
whose fans just like run the gamut you
got game of thrones star wars fans
dc comic fans because of now wonder
woman 1984
but be honest with me which fans are the
rowdiest
that's a good question because my first
introduction
to some serious bands was game of
thrones
i was doing a play in new york when the
episodes that i was in was airing and i
gradually
you know started to get kind of noticed
in my regular new york routine
on the train you know like drinking my
coffee yeah and i've been told about the
dc
fans and i can't wait to get more of an
impression once the movie comes out
my first instance with the incredible
star wars fans was that the star wars
experience
in chicago and they made the
announcement of the cast of the
mandalorian and i remember stepping out
onto that stage and it was like being on
the receiving end of a chat
oh my god it was just a wash with like
cheer
and you know and i thought i could get
used to this
careful have you gotten used to it
circumstances have been so unique
in the time that a show like the
mandalorian and is existing in this year
particularly so
it's different i always think about that
experience because i had more direct
contact with everybody i remember i was
given
plaques i was invited into like the
rebels group and the mercenaries i
really miss that there hasn't been
enough of it to get used to yet
i look forward to getting used to it
okay let's talk some max lord here and
without spoiling
too many deeps you know for the mad
fandom out there
your character has the ability to
persuade the masses
it is something to be sane but are you
as persuasive as max lord in real life
i know that like when you want something
we surprise ourselves
how we go after it and i'm talking about
you know like
and you know the last piece of the
brownie down to you know
the job that's going to change my life
you know i think about that a lot
i try to keep that in check because i
would say maybe there is a natural
inclination
to improvise you know in a in a
limitless way
how to get what i want i want that last
piece of brownie
and i don't want to feel bad about it
either yeah that's right i like that
but i feel like this message is quite
timely and how timely do you feel like
this message is
you know in a world of today we want
things when we want them
uh without really thinking about the
repercussions of them
you know yeah there's some beautiful
messaging in this movie
i i don't think we realize that the
context would be
so impactful in the time that it is
going to be shared with the world but i
knew that
in the incredible patty jenkins gal
gadot wonder woman fashion
we would be messaging as much humanity
and hope in in in contrast to a culture
that that
that really is asking for more and more
and more and more and more you know
or a side of the culture that that is
capable of that that
it's never enough max lord being the
complete personification
of that and of course it's a symptom
that that is dangerous for all of us in
the world that we live in
there's a lot of love in this film but
there's a lot of fighting but max lord
isn't too much of a fighter he doesn't
really get super
physical it's all really mental so yeah
were you like heck yeah
it was so nice for the women to take
that over they're the ones that are
kicking butt
and i'm grateful i
yeah you definitely fought with your
words and your mind and not your body
but it must have been cool being a fly
on the wall and watching
kristen and gal go at it right it was
incredible it really really was
there's a sort of longer sequence that
my
my character is perfectly involved in
i'm literally scrambling around on the
floor trying to just get out of the way
i love
being an audience member to that
especially if it means that i will not
be taking the salt back
or you know asking for ice packs at the
end of the day
exactly right okay we talked about it
earlier the fandom that is the
mandalorian fans you know
gotta ask you about the season did you
have any idea of yoda's real name
grogu and were you completely shocked
when you heard the name
i did know how long did you know
at the start of season two i mean when i
got the scripts for season two
you know for it to be as good as it is
they are
well prepared to start shooting and um
my favorite thing about it is how part
of the
creative process i'm invited to at least
observe experience and contribute
you know whatever will occur to me um
and
and so uh giancarlo and dave filoni
they they they get me the scripts um
before we get
into shooting so i know it all baby
oh you want to spill any jeets to us
right now pedro
oh child come on now come on now that's
my statistics side coming out too it's
like yeah that's your mac side coming
out how many more seasons do you see it
running
i have no idea i have no idea because i
think that quality
is always going to override quantity so
as long as it's
staying at the the this incredible
standard to which it is
at it's more a matter of of that than
anything else
you know what i mean
[Music]
nothing good is born from
and lies is not what you think
[Music]
you